the devastating power of a tornado trees
torn up cars tossed aside homes lost
beneath the rubble residents here are
just grateful to be alive as neighbors
who ran around to make sure everybody
was okay and afterwards just seeing my
neighbor's house completely destroyed I
was just thankful man I didn't care
about the materials at that time I was
just thankful to be alive
Shoppers in Little Rock were caught off
guard by the storm the roof was ripped
off the local supermarket as they
sheltered inside the only way we knew
the tornado was coming
someone said run to the back me and
these two ladies here
we ran to the back we huddled together
and we pray for our lives further north
in Belvedere Illinois at least one
person died and dozens were injured as
the roof of the theater collapsed
hundreds were inside attending a sold
out concert
yet more tornadoes cost a deadly path
through the Midwest and south of the
United States hundreds of thousands were
left without power in Illinois Arkansas
and Tennessee
such was the scale of the destruction
that the Arkansas governor declared a
state of emergency we are resilient and
no matter what comes our way we will get
back up the next day and keep moving we
will help our neighbors we will ensure
that every Arkansas
who needs assistance has it our message
and our mission is really simple the
people come first and the paperwork will
come second
and as devastated communities begin to
piece their lives back together they
must do so knowing that yet more
dangerous storms are forecast for the
days ahead Matthew Thompson Sky News